después de acampar y recorrer grandes
distancias en bicicleta tú decides
regresar directo a casa en bicicleta
viajando a una velocidad constante
después de dos horas tú te encuentras a
10 km de tu casa después de dos horas tú
te encuentras a 10 km de tu casa y
después de cuatro horas de viaje te
encuentras a 5 kilómetros de casa una
vez iniciado el viaje en bicicleta
cuántas horas te tomará regresar a casa
de hecho este es un arte de tomar a
regresar a casa vamos a poner en una
tabla estos datos mi tabla va a hacer de
tiempo
y distancia tiempo dos horas distancia
10 km ahora el tiempo de 4 horas la
distancia es de 5 km como se viaja a una
velocidad rápida es constante vamos a
ver cuál es este valor constante cuando
en el tiempo pasó de 2 a 4 se incrementa
en 2 incrementa en 2 y en la distancia
pasó de 10 a 5 es decir restó 5 menos 5
si el tiempo se llegará a incrementar
otras dos horas s se pasará de 4 a 6 se
incrementa otras dos horas qué pasará
con esto este se va a decrementar en 5
este va a pasar acá se decremento en 555
va a ser ser quedando a 0 kilómetros de
casa es decir que aquí ya llegamos
aquí hemos resuelto lo que nos pregunta
nos va a llevar seis horas regresar a
casa ahora voy a hacer una pregunta que
no nos hacen aquí que es que lejos
estábamos cuando iniciamos el viaje de
regreso encontramos algunos datos
previos vamos a copiar esto y pegamos lo
más abajo para hacer espacio con estas
maravillosas herramientas como esto
vamos a hacer un poquito de espacio aquí
hacia abajo completamos la línea qué
pasa si yo a este 2 le restó 2 si paso
de aquí acá y le restó 2 aquí me va a
quedar un ser
a este 10 en lugar de restarle 5 le sumó
5 si paso de aquí acá y le sumó el 5 me
va a quedar 15 así que estábamos a 15
kilómetros de distancia cuando iniciamos
el viaje
la forma de pensar en esto quito esto de
acá es pensar que iniciamos en cero y lo
aumentamos 2
y a este 15 y le restamos 5 mantenemos
la misma proporción y estos datos se nos
van cumpliendo se siguen conservando
esta proporción vamos a graficar lo para
terminar de comprender mejor este
resultado dibujemos nuestros ejes
nuestro eje horizontal nuestro eje
vertical este es el tiempo y esa es la
distancia hagamos las divisiones entre
llega hasta 6 vamos a ver esto es 2 4 6
y en distancia se llega hasta 15 vamos a
ver que sea más o menos 15 5 10 15 5 10
y 15 y ahora encontramos nuestras
intersecciones en t y d
tenemos la intersección en d cuando el
tiempo es igual a 0 es 0,15 este punto
de aca 0,15 y mi intersección en t
cuando d es igual a 0
qué es este y es 606 el valor entre 0 m
60 y ahora unimos estos puntos para
tener nuestra línea es una línea recta
ya lo habíamos dicho porque la velocidad
es constante
unimos estos dos puntos y una pregunta
que quizás estén haciendo ustedes es
cómo podemos cuantificar la velocidad o
la rapidez en la que viajamos bueno ésta
está relacionada con la inclinación de
esta línea la inclinación a la pendiente
es el cambio en el eje vertical con
respecto al eje horizontal esto
su pendiente
se define como el cambio en el eje
vertical que es el de la distancia entre
el cambio en el eje horizontal que es
del tiempo y de la tabla vimos que el
cambio en la distancia es de menos 5
menos 5 entre el cambio en tiempo que es
de más 22 así que está pendiente es
igual a menos 5 medios
veámoslo aquí en la gráfica cuál es este
cambio del punto a 210 de este punto 210
este de acá al 45 a este otro punto de
acá 45 este nuestro cambio en la
distancia de aquí acá es de 5 hacia
abajo menos 5 y el cambio en el tiempo
es de aquí acá de 2 a 4 es de 2 menos
5,2 así que la distancia que ese viaje
es igual a 15 menos 5 medios por el
tiempo recorrido y es bueno ver todos
estos aspectos de este problema aunque
nos haya llevado más tiempo y cálculos
que al resolver solo la pregunta que nos
hacían originalmente